just found out my ex-girlfriend's
getting breast implants that blew my
mind i use the term breast implants i
like the term fake breasts doesn't make
sense to me because the breasts are real
it's just the [ __ ] inside that's fake
the breasts are still real it's kind of
like the bible the book is real it's
just the [ __ ] inside that's fake
some people get mad we make fun of our
religion we're trying to forgot if you
believe it just believe it wasn't what i
say i believe in gravity and somebody's
like hey gravity's not real i'll be like
all right good luck out there
i wouldn't be mad i'm just like hey stop
the roof yeah yeah
i'm so jealous that religious people
must be nice you know it's amazing to
believe in something have faith and all
that blah blah blah oh my god that's
incredible like i tried with religion i
really tried i prayed nothing happened i
talked to god nothing happened zero
results zero how is that acceptable
i feel like we let religion slide
because it's free
you know if you had to pay for religion
once a month like directv you'd be like
well this [ __ ] isn't working
i'm getting ripped off here i'm gonna
try that agnostic package yeah
the bible sucks too the bible's a real
buzz kill huh they hate anything fun
they hate the gays hate trans isn't that
gonna be great when doing stuff so
sexually advanced not even in the bible
you know like i love having sex with my
robot the guy's like
all right you're good
[Music]